most entrepreneurs like to break rules
but today i'm going to share with you 20
rules for entrepreneurship
[Music]
by the way stick around to the very end
i'm not going to give you the 20th rule
but i'm going to give you a pdf that has
the 20th rule in it so let's get right
into it number one rule don't let
depressions and recessions scare you
that is automatic some of the biggest
entrepreneurs ever started at the worst
time i started my insurance company in
09 which right after 08 aig is about to
go out of business everyone's scared no
one's given contracts insurance
companies are worried about maybe
they're going to go out of business bear
stearns went out of business it was such
a
terrible time to start a business but we
did not let that scare us we let it
inspire us because every single paper i
was reading at that time was telling us
the end of the world is coming but
typically
the biggest entrepreneurs get started
during depressions and recessions so do
not let it scare you number two
only one percent of pr firms earn every
penny
that you pay them and here's what i mean
by it every pr firm is going to tell you
we're going to share with you how to
become viral we're going to share with
you how to get out there and gain
customers we're going to and for only
ten thousand dollars a month in a six
month contract of sixty thousand dollar
commitment we're gonna help you xyz
money and then you do that and the first
month nothing happens
second one they get you one article
that's a newswire or whatever and then
third month maybe they get you on a
podcast and unfortunately like and it's
like well it's because you know we're
trying to get it but i think what we we
need to restrategize and the whole point
is they haven't done a lot they haven't
earned that money that thirty thousand
dollars you pay them for three months
it's been profit so instead of trying to
hire pr firms that act like they can
solve every problem for you be the pr
from today you need to learn how to beat
a pr from youtube facebook twitter tick
tock there's so many different ways to
do it start your own podcast start your
own blog start your own vlog there's so
many ways to do it so rather than hiring
a pr firm you be the pr for number three
distribution is everything either find
distribution or create distribution but
whatever you're doing if you have a
great product that you don't have
distribution nobody cares you have to
have a great product but you need to
have a distribution without a strong
distribution channel there are many
great products that are never found you
got to figure out a way whether you're
going to create that distribution for
yourself or you're going to leverage
somebody else's number four you know
this whole thing about don't sweat the
small stuff don't worry about it life is
soaked don't sweat the small stuff you
cannot do that as an entrepreneur maybe
a artist can do that maybe a you know
person in a completely different world
can do that as a business person if you
don't sweat the small stuff you know
what the finances ah who cares i don't
need to see the statement it's totally
fine oh really oh really
you're about to not make payroll to all
your employees and then they're going to
come back and say hey my employ my my
check bounced and seven of your
employees come to you and tell you my
680 dollar check bounce how i don't know
and they said well i was telling you we
got it oh my gosh well you weren't
sweating the small stuff sweat
everything sweat everything when you
first get started number five constantly
stay in creation mode what got you
excited about starting a business is you
were wanting to create something better
a better way of doing something a better
way of serving the client a better way
of you know going out there and
delivering the product right and then
that got you to survive the first year
two years but then sometimes the
entrepreneurs goes away from creation
mode and they become too logical and
boring and then nothing keeps recreating
there's no new things that are being
created constantly stay in creation mode
what if we do this and what if we do
that hey grab a pen and you know marker
hey come on guys let's get in the room
three four of us hey what if we do this
paul what do you think about this what
do you think about how about if we did
this constantly creation mode creation
mode creation mode because when you're
staying in that you're looking at new
ways of doing things better right number
six manage anxiety you're gonna have a
lot of anxiety it's just gonna happen
it's part of the game because
you're worried about you're gonna run
out of money you're worried about your
personal life your marriage your
relationship your friendship your mom
your dad your brother your sister
missing birthday parties missing
anniversaries missing weddings are like
oh my gosh i feel like i'm letting
everybody down what the hell is going on
is this what i really signed up for
trying to figure out a formula on
anxiety one of the basic things that i
always tell people i had to learn this
thing years ago i made a video about
anxiety i think seven six years ago when
i was going through anxiety attacks
myself is the following that's a basic
formula anytime you get depressed you're
spending too much time thinking about
the past
anytime you get too anxious you're
spending way too much i'm thinking about
the future anytime you're peaceful
you're here so as an entrepreneur we're
typically living here right one day one
day one day that's fine because you're
cast in the vision where we're going but
it's not like what if this doesn't work
out there's a big difference between
vision and anxiety because vision is
like one day we're going to be the
biggest one day we're going to be there
versus oh my gosh what if this thing
doesn't happen next week what if that
thing doesn't happen what if this what
anxiety anxiety anxiety anxiety anxiety
so have that pendulum in your head why
am i getting depressed i'm spending too
much time thinking about a decision i
made six months ago that was the wrong
one get over it learn from it let's move
on oh my gosh i can't even breathe
can't control that stay right here okay
next number seven focus on vision when
you wanna quit there's gonna be times
you don't feel like doing this thing
anymore it just doesn't make any sense
to say why did i get started in the
first place what's the vision resell it
to yourself over and over and over again
because you will need it and there will
be times
when you want to quit number eight
listen to your critics here's what i
mean by listening to your critics some
people don't listen to critics they're
haters they're this they're that you
have no idea
how much i would want to hear what the
critics were saying let me explain to
you why because critics
they don't know how to do this and let
me explain they
they know
like what you're doing wrong that you
haven't learned yet because somebody
who's ahead of you they have experience
and they probably shouldn't tell you
your weakness
because if they tell you and improve
that now you can compete against them
right so critics don't know how to do
that they emotionally are so much about
making sure everybody knows that they're
bigger than you that they forget to do
that so yeah that company wrote well let
me tell you what that company does and
they they'll tweet it and they'll
facebook it or they'll comment or
they'll say something like
you know what he's right
we do need somebody in this area
huh thank you for the feedback hater
appreciate you and i didn't even need to
pay your consulting fee you're fantastic
i'll send you thank you letter 10 years
from now you're the best right so think
about it from that mindset i cannot
believe he said this to me relax he may
be making you a lot of money by giving
you that
criticism number nine find your blue
ocean figure out a way to do
something that's different than
everybody else's and if you've never
read the blue ocean strategy the whole
idea is do something that
differentiates yourself from the entire
marketplace don't be like a me too
company figure out a way to be different
than all your peers if you haven't read
blue ocean it's probably my top three
business books i recommend to every
entrepreneur i highly recommend you go
buy that book i don't make money off of
it i don't write it a guy named wc chen
wrote it if you've never read it we'll
put the link below number 10
win the right people over you're going
to
sometimes people are going to be like
well i don't give i don't care if i'm
done i don't care what people are
thinking i don't care this this this
that it may be good post for instagram
it may be good post for facebook or
twitter but it ain't good for business
you do need to win the right people over
like for me i had to win the right
people over when i first started the
insurance company and i went to a state
and i met with the ceo and i got the
contract two months later i lose that
contract i couldn't have said the hell
with this guy i'm never gonna do
business with this guy no no no i sat
there and i said okay i gotta figure out
a way to win this guy over you know how
long it took me to win that guy over
five years but i had to win them over
because i wanted that product i wanted
that business so you have to be sitting
there saying who is it that i want to
win over then put a strategy to go out
and win this person over maybe it's
through execution results maybe it's
through
winning over the five people that they
respect the most and they go and tell
that person did you know what this guy's
doing but you got to figure out a way to
win the right people over so make a list
of the right people and put a strategy
to go win those people over number 11
celebrate fast you know a lot of people
celebrate way too long when you're small
you don't have time to celebrate for a
week and get away no oh my gosh we just
got our 200 customer this is sick it's
so awesome boom awesome
next write it in oh my gosh we just got
our 200 customer babe let's go to vegas
for a week okay now you're about to go
to out of business so don't celebrate
too long figure out a way to celebrate
fast number 12 your word matters more
when you're small when i was small and
nobody respected me because i was just
getting started
if i told you i'm going to be there at
three i'm there at 2 45. okay
if i told you i'm going to pay back on
the 25th i paid you back on the 20th if
i told you i'm gonna send an email with
the nine points i'm gonna send that
email to you with nine points your word
matters so your words gonna matter
forever but your
word matters a million times more when
you're small a million times more
anything you ask anything people ask of
you do it because
so so eventually the repetition got out
there and says hey who's this patrick
with every guy oh if he says he's going
to do this they're going to do it i just
they're going to do it oh really he's
going to do it he said this oh did he
ask those two questions for me at the
end where he says so when can i expect
to get back on this and if i do this and
when can we expect to get this yes he
has that from he asks it from everybody
oh okay great so yeah that's kind of how
he is but he's going to deliver i wanted
that reputation when i was small so it's
going to matter to you a lot number 13.
sometimes entrepreneurs become
entrepreneurs because they don't want to
ask anybody for help but there's no way
in the world you're going to do anything
big without being able to ask people for
help if this is a vice of yours get used
to asking people for help if you don't
you will be out of business in no time
because you need a lot of help to run a
business next number 14
be aggressively patient
be aggressive you're playing offense
you're doing all that other stuff but at
the same time your patience some stuff
is just going to take a long time right
my dad would always say no matter what
you do no matter how much money you got
no matter how much you can lift no
matter how many books you read no matter
what you do 40 weeks is baby god tells
you it's 40 weeks do whatever you want
to do you can have all the money in the
world 40 weeks some things require
patience some things you can't force for
to come quickly right
you got to wait for that certain things
you do your part you work your tail off
you do your thing but at the same time
be patient about it not just patient but
aggressively patient number 15. it's
okay to be lucky you know a lot of
people are like well i don't like him
when he told me you're lucky you know
lucky is when preparation meets answer
that's what luck is i didn't get lucky
at work listen call me lucky
i could care less you could call me like
oh you want you're right i don't because
i welcome getting lucky
my son says the other day because we had
a conversation about it he says you know
what's your middle name james what's
tico's middle name gabriel what's seno's
middle name
rose what's brooklyn's middle name ivy
what's daddy's middle name the other kid
say daddy doesn't have a middle name
dylan says yes he does he told me if
they let him make a middle name his
middle name is going to be lucky i said
yes because your daddy's so lucky i
don't mind being lucky okay so welcome
luck like no no don't have to pry to not
welcome like cause luck wants to be
attracted to a person that's okay
getting lucky i don't mind getting lucky
okay it's okay when you're getting lucky
as well don't complain about it number
16.
join a local advisory group like a
whatever you can find five we do our own
thing that we have our masterminds i
have a general mastermind i have an
elite mastermind and there's certain
qualifications to be a part of it i run
quite a few per month with ceos around
the world if you want to apply for we'll
put the link below but i recommend go go
find one go to vistage go to ypo go to
eo whatever you can find that there is a
local advisory group
go find it they are so effective they're
so proven because you're learning about
challenges other people are also going
through where you're not alone many
times you'll come in and share your
problem
and you may get the answer to the
problem you had but the other six people
shared their problems and you needed to
learn from their problems more than the
problem that you actually had i don't
know if this makes sense so there's an
element to being part of the right
advisory group number 17 keep that
working keep shaking hands i know it's
coveted time so they say don't shake
hands i always ask the question when i
put my hand on there john do you shake
hands i do here we go do you do this you
tell me i'm good either way but
constantly shaking hands constantly
sitting there networking meeting with
people talking to them what about this
what about that what about this
constantly be doing that because you
never know what that one relationship is
going to lead you to technology
partnership investment
so keep networking and by the way i have
a video i did on networking remind me
kai at the end that i'm going to put
that as one of them number 18. don't
worry about being embarrassed by the mvp
too often we want the perfect product
you know what our first website had let
me tell you what our first website had
our first website i had this idea
because i was playing so much suduko i
don't know if you know the game suduko
our first website had an insurance
company's website had daily horoscope on
there who the hell in the insurance
industry would think about putting a
daily horoscope this guy did because he
thought it was a great idea think about
that idea right there had sudoku on my
side because i said people going to come
here they're going to play suduko and
they're going to see the interest on
other products that we offer maybe
they're going to buy a product from us
but they're going to play soduko that
was my website can you imagine how crazy
that is right actually think about that
so and people are like what is this guy
thinking about they were making fun of
it i don't care you have to be a bit
shameless do not worry about being
embarrassed about your first
mvp your first product that you have do
not try to be the perfect product right
off the bat just be okay the fact that
you're launching because by the feedback
you get from people you're going to get
better at it number 19
constantly read biographies and let me
tell what i mean by biographies
go read teddy roosevelt's biography go
read jobs biography
go read other people that were building
a business that were that did something
and they won the other day i watched a
schumacher document or watch a center
document or watch documentaries of
people that went through a lot of
hardship and they won here's why
because what happens is you're sitting
you're going through hardship and you
feel sorry for yourself
and here read a hardship about teddy
roosevelt that lost his kid or lost his
wife and you're like what are you
bitching about
would you exchange your problem of
working this many hours versus this guy
yeah i'm sorry teddy you keep your
problems i'm good stop whining and get
back to work right
so reading the right biographies or
watching the right documentaries can
actually give you more hope and more
confidence to go out there and do your
work so i highly recommend reading the
right biographies if you want to get a
list on it maybe send me a tweet at
patrickbetdavid i may give you a few
biographies for you to consider reading
so having said that 20th rule if you
wanna text the word business
to three one zero three four zero one
one three two one more time text the
word business to three one zero
three four zero one one three two or if
you're international click on the link
below subscribe to our newsletter and
we'll send them pdf with point number 20
on it i've got two other videos i want
you to watch one of them is 10 things to
do before you become an entrepreneur
some of you guys maybe employees you're
thinking about it you might maybe i want
to do maybe i don't want to do it 10
things to do before you become an
entrepreneur and the other one is
14 uh tips on networking how casino i
did some network like casanova if you've
never watched it i explained how i
network so either one of these click on
and watch them and if you got a lot of
value from the video give us a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]